you have two children your wife you guys
planning a vacation this summer what
you're gonna do
yeah no we're not doing anything we're
not you Silas play the attitude I'm done
I'm dying
I'm stop running after what is everybody
running after you know you get off with
work you get summertime comes I got to
go I got to go vacation somewhere I got
to run to Italy I got to go some stop it
no you don't just hang out at home it'll
be so much better than sure
stop with the cruises stop you know like
a fruit no I can cruise nobody go stop
with the cruises it's a dumb idea of a
good vacation anything you can do on
that boat you can do here on land water
slides horrible magic shows it's all
here don't need to go out into the
middle of the ocean where you do not
belong right with two thousand other
people floating around on this giant
white toilet the buffets the buffets oh
my god seven meals a day yeah they took
our three meals they added four more to
it yeah and what does everybody do they
waddle off to the rooms and take a dump
in the ocean never mentioned in the
advertising oh I was in we were in Italy
when we did go on vacations and I was in
this tiny town and you couldn't fit one
more person in this town there was there
was no every hotel every restaurant
booked in the middle of dinner this
cruise ship pulled up it was like our
city was being attacked by another city
the gangplank came down they can waddle
and out there Tommy Bahama and there's
flip-flops they ate everything they
could find went back out on the boat and
took another dump
okay well do you prefer if you were
gonna go on a vacation would you want a
beach vacation would you want something
more active do you like activities no no
activities no stop stop it I knew it was
gonna be that easy I believe it I
stopped ziplining in beautiful places
what are you doing what are you doing
well you go to these isn't it enough
when you go to these places like Jamaica
or the Hawaii isn't it enough to try and
absorb the beauty that is that place in
the five days you have there do you
really have to zip do you have to strap
yourself in a dirty harness and a lice
ridden helmet and be kicked off a
platform by a non regulated local fly
through the treetops of the jungle book
in a towel sit at the ocean's edge enjoy
your life look at you want to zip line
through a horrible place I get it you
want to zip line through Riverside or
Long Beach well then you should be up
above everything moving as quickly as
you can trying not to get shot it's the
same with the parasailing I don't
understand the Paris nobody needs your
white ass being flown around like a kite
over these two poverty-stricken villages
all the children are following hoping
some money falls out of your bathing
suit to buy a coconut and live another
day
you